(upbeat music)
- What's going on Addy Hour fam?
Welcome to part two of our
episode on thriving or burnout
in mentoring, pastoring,
service and vocation.
We had a great episode last
week with Dr. Christine Pfund.
This week we're joined
by Dr. David Ireland,
and we're gonna continue
and extend that conversation
also thinking about aspects
of leadership as well.
So just by way of introduction,
I want to let you all know a
little bit about Dr. Ireland.
He is the founder and lead
pastor of Christ Church,
which is a 10,000 member
multi-site congregation
in North Jersey.
It has over 70 nationalities represented
in that congregation,
and he is someone who has a
lot of leadership experience
as well.
He also is someone who is important
in the world of diversity,
equity, inclusion.
He's been a diversity
consultant to the NBA.
He's also led chapel services
for the New York Giants,
the New York Jets, and
also the US Pentagon.
He's also a prolific
author of over 25 books,
so someone who has had a lot of influence
in a lot of different spheres.
He also holds a range
of different degrees,
so he has graduate degrees in engineering,
also in theology, and
organizational leadership,
and also in social innovation.
So I think you're really
gonna enjoy the conversation
that we had, again,
kind of continuing this theme
of thinking about thriving
or burnout, practical
ways that we can do that,
and ways we can also create
cultures and environments
that facilitate those
times of productivity
and sacred rhythms of rest as well.
Just wanna remind you all as well
that I do have a new newsletter,
so if you wanna check that out,
you can find it on Substack.
You can read it there
or you can subscribe.
You can also go straight to the URL,
so niiaddy.substack.com,
and you can find that newsletter.
Lots of different topics
I'm talking about there
about my journey,
and also kind of amplifying
and going into more depth
about some of these podcast
conversations as well.
So again, really glad
that you all are here.
Do also want to take a time to acknowledge
the timing of this
episode release as well.
So this episode is coming
out on February 1st,
so the start of Black History Month,
something that's very important obviously
for us in this country,
but unfortunately also comes on the heels
on what has been a very difficult week
and a very difficult few weeks,
with everything that's been going on
around the conversation of the tragic
and unfortunate killing of Tyre Nichols.
Again, another black man
killed at the hands of police.
And this of course is coming
on the heels of ongoing tragedies,
even as we took time to pause
with everything that happened
in California with the shootings again,
which should have been
at a time of celebration,
with the Lunar New Year.
But again, we see just the
ugliness of these incidents
that continue to happen.
And so I did want to take
time to acknowledge that,
there are range of emotions
that I've been feeling
that many of you have been feeling as well
as they always are during these times,
grief and mourning, the
anger, the frustration,
sometimes feelings of hopelessness.
And so I did want to
just take time to pause
and acknowledge that, and
also to remind all of you
as listeners,
just to give yourself time to process
and to support one another as well.
Even in this episode,
as we're thinking about things
like thriving and burnout,
to also acknowledge that this trauma
from seeing these images,
the vicarious trauma from
thinking about these things,
that is real.
Many people and experts
have talked about that,
and there may be things that
you feel at different points
in time that hit you.
So to give yourself time to pause,
to know that it can also
affect how you navigate
through the day,
and as we think about this
aspect of thriving or burnout,
knowing that can also lead to places
where you're feeling stretched thin.
I know for me,
I've had to be very
intentional about having
those times of reflection,
but then just also
having times to step away
from going too deep into that.
Many psychologists have
suggested not to watch that video
and just the imprint
that it can leave on you,
that's a personal decision
you all have to make.
But I also just want to
extend just my sympathies
to the family members, to the friends,
to the entire community,
and for what a lot of us
are navigating through.
Obviously it has been said in many places,
he should still be here,
that is just the reality.
That's not something that we can change,
but we can honor his life,
and hopefully we will get to
a place of having true change.
So again, obviously a somber moment,
but I did want to take time
and acknowledge that as well.
So with that,
I hope you all are doing
the best as you can
to take care of yourselves,
to practice that self-care,
to be in support, to be in
community of one another.
And I hope that as you
listen to this episode,
that even as you're thinking
about some of those things,
that you'll be able to think about that,
and as well, know that we
are all here for each other.
Even in the way that we had this episode,
even though it was recorded
before these police videos
were released,
to know that the tone of that also is in
that state of support and
how we can support each other
as a community.
So with that,
I hope that you all get a
lot out of this episode.
I think you're really going
to be encouraged by it.
And there's a lot that Dr. Ireland shared
that will really be
beneficial and uplifting
for all of us, so enjoy.
(upbeat music)
Well, it's my pleasure again,
to be able to host this conversation.
It's been a while since we've
had consistent episodes,
but I'm really excited that we
are moving into that in 2023.
And this is a topic that
we'll be talking about today
that a lot of you have been asking about
in terms of burnout,
something that is definitely relevant
that a lot of us experience,
maybe in the midst of
or maybe on the verge of or coming out of.
So again, I think this is just gonna be
a wonderful conversation.
Part two in a sense,
as we already have talked with Chris Pfund
and really just excited to be
able to host Dr. David Ireland
on the Addy Hour podcast.
Thank you so much for being here.
- My pleasure. Thank
you so much, Dr. Addy.
It's a joy.
- Of course,
and I know we were talking
a little bit offline
before we started the recording,
but I wanted to give you
all just an introduction
to Dr. Ireland.
I know you've heard the intro that I gave,
but just to give you a sense of who he is
because so many things that he is about
really are embedded in
our podcast conversation.
Too many things for us to talk about
in the one conversation today,
but also just want to give
you all a sense of who he is,
and even as you heard from Dr. Pfund,
knowing that she was also excited
about this dialogue today.
So Dr. Ireland,
if you could just give us a
little bit about your journey
into ministry,
I guess going all the way as
far back as you want to go,
but maybe starting from
your college days to here
and how you've gotten to this place.
- Well, my pleasure.
I actually was an atheist.
I told people I was a scientific atheist
from the teenage years,
and I started college at 16,
and I did my first degree in engineering,
mechanical engineering.
And then when I graduated at 20,
and I went into graduate school,
did a master's in civil engineering,
and so I worked in that profession.
But at the age of 20,
I had this life transforming experience
or series of experiences.
And that's where I became then,
a follower of Jesus Christ.
I didn't even realize I was praying.
I just got to the end
of my rope, so to speak.
And after graduating, I started thinking,
"There must be more to life
than making a lot of money,
marrying a pretty wife,
having the nice house."
Even though I had none of those things,
and I remember sitting on
the edge of my dormitory bed
and I said, "God, if
you're real, change me."
And he changed me.
And my outlook, my worldview has changed.
The way I thought about
myself was changed.
And then I started to
build this relationship
with Jesus Christ.
And I practiced engineering
for about six years
after graduate school,
and then I transitioned into
ministry, went to seminary,
then went on, did a PhD,
then did lots of post-doctoral work.
I'm a school guy, so yeah.
So that's where I was.
I did my last postgraduate
degree at University of Cambridge
in England in social innovation,
and so I'm always learning
and trying to grow.
- Right. Well, you're in good
company being a school guy.
And I know that a lot of our listeners
will be able to relate to that as well.
But even those who maybe
haven't been lifelong
people in our education
spaces who are just continuing
to learn so many different ways,
so appreciate you sharing
that story as well.
And just to unpack a little bit,
I know we were talking about
your most recent degree,
but if you could tell our
listeners about some of the work
that you've done over the years
in terms of what you talked about
in terms of cultural competency,
because a lot of those
things are also near and dear
to what we've talked
about on this podcast.
- My research interest
has always been diversity,
more particularly building
multiracial organizations.
And so when I did my
dissertation years ago,
about 20 years ago,
it was on the black-white relationship
in large multiracial churches
in America to understand that.
This most recent dissertation was on,
how do you help white leaders
enjoy developing a lifestyle
of intercultural competence?
That means how do you, because right now,
a lot of white males
particularly feel demonized
when it comes to having
conversations about diversity,
equity, and inclusion.
And so, I have then worked on that space.
And so I do consulting for
some of the major corporations
in addition to being a pastor.
I'm a pastor of a church, about
10,000 people, and has 75,
or I should say 70
different nationalities.
And so I provide leadership
to Asians, whites,
Native Americans, blacks, Latinos,
so the whole spectrum, so to speak,
and so I'm honored to do that.
And I say that and I give that information
because the racially
diverse church in America
is a very rare animal.
And for someone then to be of color
leading a racially diverse church,
that's like an Elvis
sighting, so to speak.
I mean, it represents
less than 1%, so to speak,
statistically.
So it's very rare, but it's
an intentional process.
You don't bring about
diversity by happenstance.
There's intentionality, there's planning,
and there's a lot of heart
change and introspection,
those kinds of searching and
probative investigative things,
so you can be able to understand.
So it's almost even like
when I deal with preaching,
I've gone through where
you have individuals
who listen to your sermons,
be it black, white,
Asian, atheist, agnostics,
and they give feedback.
How am I being interpreted?
How am I coming across?
What are you hearing?
In other words,
am I speaking cross-culturally?
Am I speaking to everybody?
And unless we go through
that type of reflection
and I should say that exercise,
we don't know how we're coming across.
We don't know how we're being interpreted.
- Yeah. Well, I appreciate you
putting that all in context,
and I a hundred percent
agree in terms of the rarity
of what you're doing as a
black male leader as well,
and how that's not often the case.
But it's really refreshing
to hear also how much
you are a learner and a listener,
even as you've listened to that feedback.
And I'd imagine that's also
facilitated your effectiveness
over the years in just
the different spaces
that God has placed you in.
- Absolutely.
In fact, I've had the opportunity to speak
in some 75 countries.
One of the countries I remember
going to, I was in Zambia,
so you think that this south
central African country
that I'll be able to be a
winner when I get there,
so to speak.
And I'm in Lusaka, the capital,
and so this is a group
of about 8,000 leaders
that were there.
And so when I started,
after my first talk,
I can feel there was this
gap between me and them.
And so I asked the host, I said,
"Am I correct in my perception
that there's this wall between us,
between me and the
leaders that are there?"
And he said, "You're correct."
And I said, "Why is that there?
I don't know them.
I have not done anything to them."
And they said this to me,
which I'll never forget,
he said, "That because you're an American
and they think that
you're gonna hurt them."
So in order to break that wall down,
even though we shared the same
race, different nationality,
different culture, but we
had the same racial makeup,
both being black, the gap was,
or I should say, in order
for me to be successful in
that conversation and that
series of conference meetings,
I had to become more vulnerable.
So the more I was able to
display a common humanity,
that's when they dropped their guards.
Because they put me beforehand
in a category that says,
you're an American.
And Americans will think
that they're better than us,
and we are quote unquote poor Africans.
And so we don't want to be hurt again.
And so they had that predisposition
before I even opened my mouth.
And so I had to help get around that.
But similar things happen no
matter what country you're in,
you find that you have to
have those conversations.
And to your point, to be a
learner, I have to ask people,
"How am I being interpreted?
How am I coming across?"
And I must then be willing
to shift and pivot quickly,
so I can be engaging with
that particular audience.
- Hmm. Well, I really
appreciate that story
and just your openness to that as well.
And I think that speaks
to volumes just to,
even the assumptions that
we carry into places,
regardless of whether we intend to or not,
both from the perspective
of those who are listening
and from you coming into that place
and not even expecting that.
So I think that's really, really powerful.
But as we've been talking
and you've been sharing again,
about all these different
things that you do,
several of which again, tie
into the podcast episode.
So I'm trying not to go too far astray
and bring us back to the
topic at hand as well,
but just thought it would
be helpful for our listeners
to kind of have that context.
But it's funny,
as I was reading your
bio and thinking about
all the different things that you're doing
and some of what you're sharing there
and this topic about burnout,
my mind immediately went to a place of,
how is this person not spread too thin
and all the things that they do?
So I wonder if you could also
just share with our listeners
as well, just your structure as it were,
in terms of how you lead.
And then also, I know we'll
get into this topic of burnout,
but what your experience has been,
either from your own personal experience
or from those that you lead
on this topic of burnout?
- I appreciate the question,
and I'll be very candid with you,
that I would look back maybe 20 years ago,
I only knew one speed.
I just, that's how I
lived, I was just working.
I tell people my love
language is productivity.
The more you produce,
the more I feel loved.
I don't need a hug. I just need,
it's almost like that line
on the Amazon website,
where's my stuff?
I just want my stuff.
But over the years, the last 20 years,
I've had to put in place
what I call sacred rhythms.
So for me,
one of the things I have to do
since I'm the public speaker,
I'll speak no more than four
weeks in a row as a pastor,
and then take two weeks off.
And I'm saying that because
there was a study that was done
years ago on the University
of Texas that said,
one hour of public speaking
is equal to eight hours of manual labor.
So your body actually goes
through the physical shock,
like I was doing a
construction worker's job,
because it's very emptying, very draining.
When you do that week
after week after week,
after a while you can
become a basket case.
So thankfully I was able to then,
to create the sacred rhythms,
you have to have effective teams.
So I took time,
I took a step back and
started to train people,
individuals that were very competent,
they had gifts, skills.
It took time to do that.
And you know, I remember as
the Zambian proverb that says,
"When you run alone, you run fast.
But when you run together, you run far."
I had been in the first 20
years of ministry running fast.
Now I run together.
And so I slowed down, put
in place gifted leaders,
trained them, took the time to train them,
the time to coach them and
to make sure and mentor them,
so that I can be able to
have these sacred rhythms.
And then help put that structure in place
for themselves so they
won't experience burnout.
- Yeah. That's really
powerful in a lot of ways,
and actually makes me think
about some of the topics
that Chris Pfund was
talking about as well.
But then even as I'm
listening to you talk,
I'm also just thinking that
some people may be hearing this
and thinking, "Well, I don't have a space
to actually slow down and take that time."
Or even when we were talking
about the burnout conversation
as well, one of the things
that she brought up was just,
when people are mentoring
so many different students
or training others,
feeling the guilt or feeling
like there isn't enough room
to actually slow down
to get to that place.
So what would you say
to someone like that,
who is feeling that tension
in a very acute kind of way?
- And I realize I have a certain privilege
because I'm lead guy, so to
speak, in my organization,
so I really set by schedule.
But I would say to that person
in a very empathetic way
to say, there are things that
can contribute to recharging.
For example, getting away,
getting away could be,
it's changing space.
That means, for example,
beauty recharges the heart.
It's going into places
where you feel energized.
Whether it's going to a museum,
whether it's going to even the mall,
and you don't have to shop and lose money
in order to get recharged.
But it's beauty that recharges you.
Not only getting away,
but getting together,
the social aspect, friends that you know,
it's having conversations, and
it doesn't have to be heady,
technical conversations. It's
just, "How are you doing?"
It's just talking.
There's some people that
I'm very close with,
when we get together and talk,
it's as if everybody else
in the room is invisible,
because we're so absorbed
in the conversation.
And the conversation, again,
may not be technical or heady,
but it's just the company.
So I would encourage individuals that say,
"Look, I can't take time off."
But you can take respites.
You can take couple hours break.
You can do certain things.
So I would say you get away,
you get together and you get alone.
The place of being alone
is a very important place
because it recharges you.
When you're able to think,
process your feelings,
get in touch with yourself,
ask yourself questions like,
"Who am I? Who am I becoming?
Who do I want to be?"
And when you ask those kinds
of pensive reflective questions
in this quiet space, it's amazing.
- Hmm. Yeah.
That's really well said.
And I am sure that listeners
will be able to take that in
and enjoy that as well.
And in a sense, I don't know
if this is the case for you,
but it made me think in a
sense about the juxtaposition
to what you talked about earlier,
just going, going, going, going.
I know for me, if I'm in
that mode, talking to others,
there's often not time
to reflect and to pause.
And sometimes,
I mean, I have had the experience
with my students as well,
that place feels productive to them,
but it actually becomes very inefficient
because they're going so hard,
they don't actually think through things
as well as they could.
And the pausing actually
creates more space
and increases the productivity
of whatever work they may
be involved in as well.
So I think that's
really, really important.
- Absolutely. In fact,
Henry Newman, the gifted
author and theologian,
said that "A person without a
quiet space, a lonely place,
it's dangerous."
So we all need to have
those quiet moments where we reflect.
And, even if it, again,
is half an hour over the course of a day.
You just need to be able to sit.
You can have quiet music
or sometimes no music,
and just sit there and just enjoy
the sacredness of the quiet space.
It recharges you.
In fact, a sign of burnout is
when there are more mistakes.
And because you're busy all the time,
so you're not as thoughtful,
not as reflective.
Another sign is a lack of creativity.
So it's almost like the
soul has a dashboard.
And when you're going through burnout,
some things increases,
other things decrease.
Those are signs,
it's almost like when you're looking
at the dashboard of your car,
if you're driving and
the things that decrease,
you see the fuel level decreases,
the heat increases of the engine.
And if you're not careful,
when we're not looking at
the dashboard of our souls
and being in touch with ourselves,
we don't know we're at
the verge of burnout.
And so when you find someone
just go off the rails,
you think it just happened?
No, it didn't just happen.
It was over a period of time,
and they just weren't monitoring
the dashboard of their
souls, looking at the things
that were increasing
and the things that are decreasing.
And so some of the things
that increase is cynicism.
When someone's at the verge of burnout,
they're more sarcastic, they're jaded,
they have this sense of humanus biting.
And it may sound witty and
clever, but it's dangerous.
And what's even more dangerous
is that oftentimes the cynic
is accurate, but the
cynicism is very destructive.
And so it's a sign though,
the increased cynicism is a sign
that you're on the verge of burnout.
And so I want to,
the listeners to be very cautious of that.
It's not being witty per se.
It's showed me that you're empty,
you're getting empty,
you're becoming empty.
- Yeah. That's really important.
And I'm glad you're
bringing that up as well.
Would you say that people just,
making maybe more of a
societal conversation
and perspective,
are we becoming more aware of that
and paying more attention to it?
Because I can see different
ways that that cynicism
may be interpreted or
even rewarded per se,
because people may still be able to be,
quote unquote productive or effective,
even if they are getting
to that place of burnout.
So what has been your
observation in that sense?
- In a technical sense,
I think that individuals
who know what to look for,
it's almost like a person
who's experienced as a parent
understands when they
see someone with a child,
a young child, and they're
just letting them do,
they're letting them run wild.
They don't understand what's
gonna happen 20 years from now.
And so an experienced person
sees it and understands it,
an inexperienced person doesn't.
A careful person who cares
about the individual will bring
that out to them in a
respectful, honoring way.
Someone that doesn't really doesn't care,
they just want to use them,
they'll work them and almost
like drive them to the ground,
give my stuff and then move on,
and they don't care about the person.
I know that the Bill and
Melinda Gates Foundation
did a study in 2020 where they engaged
the Queensland University,
and they did a study to try to find out
the impact of COVID in
regards to the burnout,
the mental issues, the mental health.
And they saw that there's a 28% increase
in these social disorders
as a result of the pandemic,
the stressors, depressive
disorder, anxiety disorder.
So depressive disorders
shot up globally 28%,
anxiety disorder increased by 26% globally
just because of the pandemic.
And not that we even changed behaviors,
just the stressors of
living in our society.
And so I would say that
particularly people
that are in leadership roles
have to deal with individuals
all the time,
they have to think about
the mental health piece
and give people spaces to recharge.
It's so important.
- Yeah, yeah.
A hundred percent agree.
And I'd be curious if there
are any anecdotes or stories
or perspectives you can share on just
if there are ways that you've actually
just tried to facilitate that?
'Cause again,
me being outside of being
in a pastoral ministry role,
but just seeing the conversations shift,
especially as a mental health advocate,
it seems that in the past,
a lot of that has been pushed to the side
or not acknowledged.
In the roles when people
are pastors and ministers,
and the expectation just to
continue to meet people's needs
and meet people's needs
without necessarily being
as attentive to their own
mental health needs or burnout.
And so, what has been your experience
in terms of receptivity,
and how have you tried to
facilitate that as well?
- I think having conversations
like this in a very frank,
direct, honest way has been very helpful.
And so I've made it a very public issue,
I've spoken on it tons of
times, not only to my staff.
I have a staff about a hundred people.
And my leadership team
is about 500 leaders.
And so I've had to then work
with these men and women
at different stages in
life and their careers
and things like that in
order to be able to say,
"Let's put certain things in place."
And so we'll put specific things in place,
such as these sacred
rhythms that I talk about
for those who are part
of our teaching teams.
We have the concept of the sabbatical
after six years of ministry,
they take three months
off and they recharge.
We have also,
there are times where
we'll put their names
on the schedule.
It says, like for me, no David Ireland,
so no DI weekend, that
means I'm off the grid.
No one's gonna be able to get ahold of me.
And even for the staff,
there are times that they work from home.
There are times that they work,
they're physically there in the office,
and we give them an opportunity
to say, "Give us input.
How are you doing?"
We created the chaplaincy program,
so that even for the staff to say,
"Okay, you go and meet with the chaplains
that we have on staff,
the mental health professionals,
unpack whatever needs to be unpacked,
we want you to be mentally healthy.
And so we have that,
and then the check-ins
periodically just to say,
"How are you doing? What's going on?"
Because oftentimes you
don't see the signs,
'cause if one of the
signs is productivity,
but there are other signs,
the loss of empathy,
the issue of compassion fatigue,
where I'm tired of caring,
I don't care anymore,
it's too exhausting.
And particularly when you're
in a caring profession,
when you're tired of
caring, there's a problem.
- Yeah. Exactly.
That's very encouraging to hear in the way
that you've described it,
that you've built it
into the culture as well.
And it seems like also leading by example,
even in your own,
'cause you talked about those
rhythms in your own life
and making sure that that's
baked in for everyone else.
Are there ways that you've
seen that perpetuate
amongst your staff and
amongst your community
just as you've kind of
tried to bake it in?
- Yeah,
what I've seen is that they've
accepted the limitations,
and limitations in the sense
that not everyone has the same capacity.
There's some people
that can juggle 15 balls
at the same time,
others that can only juggle two,
and one's not better than the other.
They're just different,
and so we have to be aware of that.
The same way children,
I'm not gonna expect a six
year old to be able to speak
as eloquently as a 15 year old,,
or the six year old to be as
patient as a college student.
I just won't expect that.
And so I'm not gonna
place pressures on them.
So, to answer your question,
people have accepted their limitations,
accepted their capacity,
and accepted the frequency
of what they need.
I remember several years ago,
my wife and I were hosting a
marriage seminar for a group.
And at one point in the seminar,
my wife spoke to all the
husbands in a separate room.
I spoke to all the wives,
and so that's always dangerous.
But after the presentation,
some of the women asked questions.
One woman was very vulnerable.
She said, "My husband and I,
we have two special needs kids
and I find myself yelling
at them so frequently,
how do I deal with that?"
And my answer to her,
it seemed as if I wasn't even
listening to her question.
I asked, because my answer
raised another question.
I said to her, "How often
do you take vacation?"
And then she paused,
because there'd not been
a frequency of vacation.
And I said,
"Let's not even talk about a vacation
where you go away for a couple of weeks.
How often do you take a respite
from providing the care to your children?"
And I said to her,
"You're not a bad mother,
you're just a tired mother.
And what you need is to build then
these sacred rhythms in your life.
And you may need more of that
because your children have special needs."
And so it requires a more frequent respite
than someone who may not be caring
for special needs children.
And I think it's giving people permission
to say, "You are a human being."
And don't label yourself
in a moralized way
when the problem is not a moral problem,
the problem is a behavioral one,
in the sense that you just
need respite in your life.
And sometimes for us it's
philosophical and even cultural.
If you come from a culture that says,
"Look, if you take a break,
you're lazy and you're bad."
Then we need to reframe
what the problem really is.
- Yeah. That's so powerful, so well said.
It actually relates
directly to even a question
that Dr. Pfund and I were
talking through yesterday
in that conversation, in terms
of mentoring and educating,
but also in ministry,
the challenge of saying
no to someone in need.
So in that example you gave,
even someone with special needs children,
and it seemed like part of it was,
I can't say no to them because
I have to be there for them
and can keep to continue.
So one thing that Chris
Pfund raised as well was just
that tension was something
that she had been
thinking through and wrestling
even as we were preparing for this episode
with her own Christian
life experience as well,
and the concept of selfless
love and those types of things.
And how do we navigate in
that space actually saying no
to someone that's in need,
versus quote unquote self-care,
when that doesn't always fit the narrative
that we are taught and talk about,
so I think the way you described
that is really helpful.
I dunno if there's anything else
that you wanna kinda add to that question.
- And I think I would add to it
that it's not wrong for me
to provide care for myself.
It's almost like the dialogue that we hear
when we get on an airplane, they tell us,
"Look, first put your own mask on
before you help that person,
whether you're a child or an aged parent
to put on their mask."
And it seems almost contrary to logic,
but it is logical.
And so when I care for myself,
and it's not about me being egotistical
or feeling that I'm more
valuable than the other,
it's about, I can't be
of any value to anyone
if I'm falling apart or if I'm
so broken or if I'm so needy.
It doesn't work that way.
And so really it's about planning.
And so even to that mom with
the special needs children,
it's about planning where you can say,
"Look, I'm gonna hire a babysitter.
I'm going to get my
parents to come and sit
for a Friday evening so my husband and I
can go out to the movies."
It's about putting some structure
in place that's practical
to have these respite
so that you can function
in an emotionally
healthy way, it's needed.
- Yeah, I highly agree.
Just to push the envelope
a little bit further,
'cause I know again,
this is just something that I know people
are wrestling with,
so even with all of those good practices,
there's still sometimes
that feeling of guilt,
that I'm still not doing what I should
or perfectionism, or even
a mixture of the two.
So how have you kind of helped people,
and maybe it's just practice in time,
but really kind of move from
that either for themselves
or I would say even the stigma that comes.
'Cause even as we've talked
about people in leadership,
pastors and ministers having
more space for themselves,
it seems that when there is a breakdown,
it's still so easy for many of us to get
to that place of judgment.
Like, "Oh, how could they falter?
They're supposed to be the model.
We're looking up to them.
If they're struggling,
then how are the rest of
us supposed to be able
to make it through a more
quote unquote following them?
- And I'll say that there
are times when I take breaks,
I still at times struggle with
a little bit of guilt saying,
"Look, I should be doing this
or I should be busy doing that,
or that thing is hanging over my head."
And, so I've never completely
overcome the idea of that.
And I think in some regards,
it's always gonna be there,
because it's just the human experience.
And it's okay.
That's the point I'm bringing out,
I think the tension of saying,
"The things I can do, but
yet I need time to recharge."
That tension's going to be there.
And I think the tension's
healthy because it's saying
in essence that I want to be responsible
and I wanna maintain a
lifestyle of being responsible
in all of my areas of
oversight, so to speak.
But in the same breath,
I'm going to make sure I take care of me,
and I think that's something
that's so important.
I can't just soldier on
and think that it's okay,
it doesn't work that way.
- Yeah. Yeah.
Well I think that's so important.
We can't pretend that
the guilt's not there,
and to still experience it,
but to know that it's still
a process that we're moving
through as well. I think
it's really helpful
- It's a learned experience.
Even Jesus in sacred
scripture tells his disciples
after a busy stint of
ministry, he says to them,
"Come with me by
yourselves to a quiet place
and get some rest."
And so he is saying to them,
"Look, you guys don't just soldier on
even though what you're
doing is so critical."
And he himself as that critical leader,
he's saying, "Look,
I need to recharge, 'cause
if I don't recharge,
I'm not going to be effective
or I'm not gonna continue
being effective."
And he was teaching them
that discipline of really
safeguarding their mental health.
- Yeah. Yeah.
I think that's really well said.
So as we've been talking,
just to pivot a little bit,
I'm also wondering a little
bit about legacy in a sense,
but then also thinking
about the next generation.
And one reason that came up,
as we're talking about the
increased rates of depression,
increased rates of anxiety,
obviously that's been
a topic of conversation
for our youth as well.
So I'm curious if that's something
that you've thought about
that's come into play
as you've talked about
a lot of these principles or even burnout
and if that is the case,
how you've tried to not translate,
but try to impart that on
the next generation as well?
- I'm involved in succession planning.
I do consulting in that regard
as well with senior leaders.
But to your point,
I think it's really helping
to create a cultural awareness
and a personal philosophy
of leadership that says,
establish and safeguard sacred rhythms.
So you're teaching them,
they're doing it anyway,
but they're doing it under the principal
that may be very quote unquote unhealthy.
And so I encourage parents, I said, "Look,
when your children have
been in school all day,
and when they come home,
don't just simply say,
'Go do your homework.'
Let 'em take a break, let 'em recharge."
And I think that for some parents,
it took a long time to wrap
their minds around that
because they came from a
family of origin that says,
"Go do your homework
and then you can relax."
And I said, "Flip the
switch, let them relax,
put some times constraints on it,
and then have them do their homework."
So this way, they feel emotionally whole,
because I think that if
we're creating children
and even the next generation
that are emotionally unhealthy,
they won't have longevity.
And I think the proof
of a good mental health
is that there's sustainability,
there's longevity.
You're not doing something
quick and then after five years,
you're burnt out.
There must be some
sustainability to what you do.
- Yeah. Yeah.
I think that's really,
really well said as well.
And even though this terms
of this burnout conversation,
that conversation that
you feel like is helpful,
that you've been able to have
with young people as well,
and if are the signs
different or is it similar
to what you mentioned before,
even in terms of some of that
cynicism and lack of empathy?
- I think both the title, if
you use the title burnout,
it drives people away.
But if I use the word sustainability,
if I have to wordsmith it in
order to make it attractional,
because if I say for example,
how to avoid burnout,
no one's coming to that seminar.
But if I say, how to be
effective for a long time,
"Okay, I'm going."
So it's almost reframing the statement
so it becomes quote unquote sexy
and attractive to leaders,
both young and old.
And that's what I've found to be the case.
So I've had to change titles,
having been the recipient of saying,
"I'm not going to that workshop,
I'm going to the one."
- Yeah. Making it palatable
and attractive to people.
I mean the packaging.
Well I know we already had Chris Pfund on,
but I'm curious if there are any,
well I'll figure out a way to do this,
but if there was
anything, if she was here,
if there's any questions
you would have posed to her
in terms of the mentorship piece,
talking specifically in academic spaces
or training or just any
thoughts around that?
- I'm mentoring as well.
I think every space there's mentoring,
'cause there has to be succession,
you have to pass on to others
the things you've learned
over the years.
And I think I would just commend her
for the discipline of saying,
"I have a responsibility
to the next generation.
They should build on the
things that I've built,
so to speak.
And so they stand on my
shoulders so they can go farther
and be able to do more things."
And so it does require then
for me to look behind and say,
"Let's pull them forward."
I remember, I had this conversation,
it was me and about maybe 20
or 30 other people I served
on the executive committee
for the last crusade
of Dr. Billy Graham's life.
It was the crusade of
2005 in New York City.
And I remember Dr. Graham
said something, he said this,
"I wish I had made friends that
were a lot younger than me,
because all my friends have died."
I mean it's one of those,
sometimes you hear
something, you write it down,
other times it's written on you.
That was written on me.
So to Chris Pfund and to other mentors,
I would say, being a mentor
means that you're making friends
with people that are younger, the protege,
younger in experience, younger in age.
But this is what one of
the quintessential leaders,
Dr. Billy Graham was remiss about saying,
"Man, I wish I would've
spent more time doing that."
I think it's dangerous when we only
are concerned about ourselves,
and our pushing things forward,
and our level of productivity
and building quote unquote our kingdoms,
and our organizations.
So there must be a turning
around to the next generation
to say,
"I have a responsibility
to help you guys fulfill
your destiny and create legacy for you,
so let me spend myself helping you."
So in other words,
I have to recharge 'cause
I have responsibility
to the next generation.
So if I don't maintain
my own mental health,
then I'm being irresponsible as a leader.
- Yeah. That's so powerful.
I mean, even thinking of my own journey,
as things have moved over
the years that tendency,
and that pull sometimes to shift,
to continue to mentor,
but to shift the circle as it were,
to peers in order to
learn from everything.
But that comment that you mentioned,
it's so powerful of what can
be missed if that goes too far,
and just the power of that.
And Chris mentioned that as well,
just the privilege of being able to mentor
and impact the next generation.
So I think that's really something
that will definitely sit with me as well,
and I'm sure with our listeners.
- I appreciate that.
And it still sits with me also
'cause I have that responsibility.
- Yeah. Yeah.
And then I know I keep bringing
things up that she said
as well, but just to tie 'em together,
just the modeling and the
example that can come from
that as well.
So one thing that she shared
about one of the studies
that they had done,
specifically around burnout
was just asking some of
those who were being mentored
about their experiences.
And some of them, this can fit
into pastoral care as well.
But looking at mentors and
thinking that those individuals
never dealt with things like burnout
or some of those mental health challenges.
And then those individuals
feeling dissuaded
and not wanting to go
into certain professions
because they were saying,
"Well if this person never
struggles with burnout,
this isn't something I can do,
so I think I need to
opt and go elsewhere."
Which is a fallacy in and of itself.
So I think it speaks
even to all the things
that you talked about before,
that what you've baked into
culture and leading by example,
that transparency,
even as you talked about
your initial experience,
I believe it was in Zambia,
having that transparency involved,
how powerful that is even
in terms of the impact
in the next generation.
- And I think even on the topic of burnout
is such a sensitive topic
that some people, it's almost,
I have to take a play out of
the playbook of individuals
that take an autocratic position,
saying I have to impose
respite for some people
because they're gonna keep running
until the wheels fall off.
And so I have to then put it
in place of this is mandatory,
this is necessary.
You have to do this,
you can't come to work tomorrow.
This needs to take place,
because they're not seeing it,
or they're not accepting
their human frailty.
And I think that is a reality
also for some leaders.
And again, it ties into
that whole cultural piece.
If they came from a cultural
background that says,
you don't take time off, that's not right.
That's wrong.
And they look at it as a moral issue,
ethical issue when it's not that.
It's a lifestyle issue to say,
"I want sustainability,
and I must be able to not
only enjoy the work of my hand
and the work of my mind, but
I must enjoy relationships
and make sure I enjoy
myself that I'm healthy."
- Yeah. Yeah.
And again,
I just think that speaks
about your effectiveness
as a leader as well.
Sometimes more of a delegate mode,
sometimes more autocratic,
and in that instance,
I think the autocratic
is so helpful to say,
"This is something that you need."
And to lead by that example
and to put into place.
In my own experience,
I've seen people in a sense,
slowly incorporate that
and then come back and say,
"Oh, okay, I actually
realized that I do need this".
And to have the benefits
of that after the fact,
I think is is huge and tremendous.
- It's so important.
It's so important.
- Yeah. So I did wanna incorporate,
'cause we had some questions
from our audience as well,
from our listeners.
And I think you've actually
touched on this pretty well,
but I'll just make sure that
I state the question as well.
But people are asking
about all these aspects of either avoiding
or kind of navigating through burnout,
especially when they
feel like more and more
responsibilities are being added on.
Kind of that sense that some people have
that those who are doing good
work then get given more work.
And I know you've talked
about this before,
but would you say to that person
who is either feeling to push
because they have to, for instance,
get promoted or move up the line,
or there's so many tasks in front of them.
And again,
if there's anything you want
to add just to that person,
who's saying, "I don't know
how to incorporate this."
- And I think that
what I've seen leaders do
is that they've negotiated
responsibilities with their
employers or their supervisors.
In other words, if their supervisor says,
"This person's very effective,
I need to give them this
because I know they'll do a good job."
They then, the employee
then has to be vocal
in a respectful way and say,
"Here's what I'm doing now.
If I add this on my plate,
something's going to give.
So of these, let's say 10
things that I'm carrying,
what would you like me to
give up in order to take on
this 11th?"
And put it back in the leader's plate.
So the leader begins to think
about priorities and timelines
and what's reasonable,
because sometimes they're
not conscious of it
because they're carrying a
whole big load themselves.
And I think the negotiation
process is important.
And even with the advent
of working from home,
what I've seen some leaders do is the fact
that they've said, "Look,
I will not take any
meetings before 8:00 AM
'cause I wanna take my kid to school
and nothing's gonna
get in the way of that,
'cause it's necessary for me to sit,
to be in the car and have those
conversations with my kids
and to check in with them,
and they block out things."
And so I think that the
idea is to negotiate
with your supervisors these realities,
and let 'em know that
you're starting to see signs
of burnout in your own life
and you don't want that to take place.
And you tell 'em even,
it's not cost effective to the company.
Even if they only
understand economic state,
make the conversation economical.
- I think that's really wise.
And I would say even a step further,
one thing that I've noticed
and been blessed is to actually
have leaders sometimes
take that initiative.
So even stepping into new
roles and having leaders say,
"Do you need me to talk to
the next supervisor in line."
To ask them to remove
something from your plate
so that you can do this
effectively and not be spread thin.
So I a hundred percent agree.
And then from both sides,
that's been really
powerful to see as well.
- Yeah.
And you feel supported when that happens.
And it makes you enjoy the workplace
and the workplace satisfaction increases
because you see that people
are genuinely concerned
about you and your wellbeing,
and not just about the productivity
or your talent, so to speak.
- Yeah, yeah.
And again, it seems to just
speak to the culture as well
of the environment or the institution
and really valuing people.
- That's so true.
- Well you've shared a lot
of just practical information
that's been really useful
and perspectives as well,
but I'm curious,
are there any last words
you'd really wanna share
with the listeners to encourage, again,
many who are listening
who are in service roles
or even in teams and trying
to meet the needs of those
in their team, and just
all these different topics.
Anything you'd wanna leave them with?
- I would just encourage 'em
to look at the dashboard of their soul
and to see where they are,
and check on your dashboard often.
Is there an increase of
cynicism? That's bad.
If there's a decrease of
creativity, that's bad.
If there's an increase
of empathy, that's good.
A decrease of productivity, that's bad.
So you look at some of the things
on the dashboard of your life,
and it'll help you see where you are.
And when you see things that are assigned
that are indicators and
say, "Wait a second,
that's not good."
Take some time for yourself and recharge.
- It's really well said. Really well said.
And I know that people are
gonna listen to this episode
more than once just to
soak in all the things
that you and Chris Pfund have mentioned.
And it's been a pleasure
to see the overlap
and for both of you,
just to see the ways that
you're really incorporating this
in who you are and how you're leading,
and how you're modeling,
and how you're also encouraging
others to do the same.
And so I'm hopeful that
there'll be a ripple effect
from this episode as well as it were.
And really appreciate the
work that you're doing,
your ministry and your time
for being here as well.
- And I appreciate the broad perspective
you've taken on this topic.
Thank you so much.
I appreciate the opportunity.
- Of course.
(upbeat music)